[Music] We are
even asking for the word “
ta’aybun” Barsha was in the water
[Music]
Its meaning is
[Music] [
Music]
Today, climate change has a
major impact on the agricultural sector, especially the
grain season. Today we have been called, within the
Tunisian Union in Lahcine Bahri, to declare a state of
water emergency to  The announcement of an increase in the state of
drought will be accompanied by many measures,
so that we stand alongside the farmers and sailors,
our goods, the
sectors, water has been continuous for years in many
areas, and those who have reached even months with
us in some areas have had years, not
even months. This is not new to them, and it is not strange to them.
Installments are being paid in installments today.  He is trying to
reduce water usage and allow us to
enter the water supply with a minimum of
20% of the water used in the months of March
and April. The star has a better stock than the
star
[music]